This is the brief on sequestered
carbon, the unignited deterrent
in US civil society.
So this analysis explores a
pretty provocative claim that
the half a billion firearms in
private hands here in America,
they're not just for sport.
They actually form a silent
structural counterweight.
Ensuring that authority always
depends on citizen consent.
First, the source identifies
these privately owned arms as a
unique fourth layer of power.
See, most nations have 3 layers,
local governance, shadow
authority like gangs, and
federal intervention.
But the US is different because
this huge private arsenal exists
to prevent any one of the other
three from getting a total
monopoly on power. 2nd, and this
is key, the main function here
is deterrence, not action, what
the author calls sequestered
carbon.
The idea is to create parity
against government overreach.
Think of it like a fire
extinguisher.
The paradox The fact these arms
aren't used in a big revolt
actually proves the deterrent is
stable and working, just like a
nuclear arsenal.
And finally, you see this
principle getting reinforced
right now.
For two decades, courts have
expanded access to modern
firearms, reaffirming the
amendment's role in protecting
this balance.
Plus, the diversification of gun
ownership to include folks like
progressive organizers
strengthens the idea that this
right is for everyone, not just
one demographic.
Ultimately, this quiet
maintenance of armed parity
eliminates the fantasy of
unopposed force.
Ensuring citizenship requires
negotiation.
Today we're looking at a really
fascinating essay.
It argues that the half a
billion private firearms in the
US are a fourth layer of power,
basically an unignited
deterrent.
Yeah, a kind of sequestered
carbon that ensures authority
doesn't become a monopoly.
It's a powerful idea.
It is.
So let's jump right in.
We have three ways to really
sharpen this thesis to make it,
you know, unassailable.
A concept this robust?
Well, you have to make sure the
foundations can handle all the
stress and I think that's where
we should start.
Absolutely.
The first point is really about
the intellectual rigor of that
central metaphor.
Right.
The essay has to fully integrate
the, let's call them the
acknowledged costs of gun
ownership.
That's the only way to make the
sequestered carbon metaphor
truly airtight and, frankly,
more persuasive.
And it's strong point right now
is that the deterrent is defined
by being unused.
The author makes that great
comparison to nuclear arsenals.
You know they don't fail just
because cities aren't burning.
Or fire extinguishers.
Exactly.
The fact that the kitchen is
still standing as proof they
work.
It perfectly frames, while layer
4's mere existence is its
success.
It's an incredibly powerful
analogy, but here's where the
structure gets a little shaky.
For me, the argument leaned so
heavily on this ideal state of
deterrence, but it only, you
know, briefly touches on the
negative outcomes, the times
when the carbon is discharged,
Crime, accidents, misuse.
And it tries to handle that by
saying those people are just
expelled from layer 4.
Exactly.
They're expelled by layers 1 and
3.
So local police and the federal
government, formal law
enforcement.
Correct, but framing it that
way, it completely sidelines the
actual societal cost of the
whole architecture.
By just saying a misuser is
expelled, the essay avoids the
very real, measurable burden
that comes with this potential
energy.
That's a huge vulnerability.
It is because any critic is
immediately going to say you're
presenting an idealized, cost
free version of constitutional
integrity, which we all know
isn't true.
I see that it creates A
structural gap.
I mean, if the deterrent is
stored energy, then some
leakage, even criminal leakage,
is just a byproduct of the
storage system itself.
Yes, you have to acknowledge the
system leaks and that leakage
has a high price.
And can we talk about that word
expelled?
If Layer 4 is truly
constitutional architecture, a
real check on power, can its
members really be expelled?
That's a great point.
Doesn't that make layer 4
conditional?
It does.
I mean, if the right is
inherent, then misuse leads to a
penalty, sure, but the structure
itself shouldn't change.
The focus shouldn't be on
expulsion from the layer, but on
the consequences that are
layered on top of it.
Exactly.
It's a crucial distinction.
It keeps the layers integrity
while still acknowledging the
legal fallout.
So the suggestion here is to
just confront the trade off head
on.
Yes, argue that preserving this
constitutional safeguard Layer 4
simply requires a certain
tolerance for burned carbon for
those societal costs.
That makes the argument so much
stronger.
It changes it from you're
ignoring the problem to a direct
statement of a necessary
constitutional choice.
It forces the reader to weigh 2
terrible outcomes, not just one
cost, against an ideal benefit.
You have the visible immediate
cost of burned carbon versus
the, you know, abstract slow
burn cost of unchecked power.
But how do you do that?
How do you make that abstract
cost feel as tangible as a crime
statistic?
That's the really hard part.
You need a dedicated passage for
it, a paragraph that really
elevates the importance of that
abstract cost.
The author has to explicitly
contrast the high visibility
costs gun violence stats against
the almost invisible costs of
Monopoly.
Things like institutional
corruption or lost freedoms.
Exactly.
You could even frame it like we
pay a visible bloody tax to
prevent an invisible slow motion
catastrophe.
You have to argue that the most
dangerous costs are the ones
that never make the headlines.
The quiet erosion of liberty.
Yes, show the reader they are
choosing the lesser of two
constitutional evils.
The maintenance cost is heavy,
but the alternative is
catastrophic system failure.
And that frames it as part of
the operating system's release
notes.
You know, this architecture
imposes a terrible but necessary
tax that is so much more
intellectually robust.
It really is OK.
So now that we've made the
argument costly and robust, we
have to make sure the audience
is even willing to listen to it.
I agree.
Which brings us to the opening.
The personal story in this piece
is just so compelling and I feel
like it's buried.
Completely so.
Resequencing the opening to
foreground the author's powerful
personal narrative would create
a much more relatable entry
point, especially for readers
outside the, you know, the usual
Second Amendment community.
Let's look at that journey.
The author moves from places
where gun ownership was
culturally peripheral.
Hawaii, DC before 88 or just a
state granted exception like in
Europe?
The UK, Germany, the Netherlands
it is, and then becomes a
convert after age 40 in
Virginia.
And that's where they find the
Second Amendment to be
architectural, not symbolic.
That discovery is the whole
reason for the essay.
It is.
It's the journey of an
intellectual who discovers the
principle through lived
experience, not just someone
defending A belief they
inherited.
That convert status is
rhetorical gold.
But the SHS jumps right into the
abstract analysis, the four
layers, the half billion
firearms.
It asks the reader to accept the
premise from line 1.
And the personal story that
serves as the proof is buried 2
paragraphs down.
It's a huge missed opportunity
for a hook.
A huge one.
It feels like the author is
trying to prove the thesis
before even telling us why they
came to believe it.
The analysis is the destination,
but the conversion story is what
gets the reader there.
So the suggestion is to use that
experience as a convert, not an
inheritor.
To frame the entire piece.
Start with the moment it all
became tangible in Virginia.
Yes, use that discovery as the
lens to introduce the whole
fourth layer idea.
The hook becomes why did someone
who spent decades in places like
DC and Berlin suddenly changed
their mind?
That immediately peaks your
curiosity, your skepticism even,
which is what you want.
It builds an emotional bridge to
the abstract analysis that
follows.
As a concrete example, you could
start with that one core
realization, something powerful
like.
Only when I moved to Virginia in
the 20 tens did the meaning of
the Second Amendment become
tangible, not symbolic,
architectural.
That's great, it grabs you
instantly.
Then you could introduce layer 4
through the contrast in the
author's own experience, moving
from a place where ownership was
theory like DC, or risk
management like in Germany.
To a place where it was
understood as parity.
Right, that makes the whole
thing personal and grounded.
It pulls the reader into the
system the author is trying to
explain.
It changes the whole structure
from a statement of fact into,
well, a kind of investigation.
The essay becomes the answer to
the question, What did the
author discover in Virginia that
was invisible everywhere else?
A massive improvement.
OK, so let's move on to the
third major point.
This is the one about
diversification, which is just
critical for proving the thesis
holds up against modern
political polarization.
It's a fascinating part of the
piece.
The author notes this modern
realignment where commentators
are warning that, you know,
LGBTQ activists, leftist
organizers, minority communities
are now arming themselves.
And the author says the reaction
from longtime advocates has been
not horror, but welcome.
Which is the ultimate test of
the whole theory, right?
Is layer four really
constitutional architecture or
is it just a political club?
Exactly so the essay must
amplify and clarify this thesis
on diversification to really
demonstrate the architectural
strength of the fourth layer.
But here's the weakness.
That welcoming feeling is
immediately undercut by this
lingering skepticism.
The political test Will you
later vote to forbid mind?
Yes, and that political caveat
makes the whole architectural
argument feel conditional.
It weakens the main point that
the amendment was for the
public, not for a specific cast.
It feels like an ideological
loyalty test is being applied at
the exact moment the author is
arguing the loyalty should be to
the Constitution, not a party.
It's an internal contradiction.
So is there a risk that by
focusing on that skepticism,
we're actually making Layer 4
seem more fragile than it is?
I think so.
The suggestion is to treat this
diversification as concrete
proof that the constitutional
core parity is working as
intended.
It's not a political risk to be
managed.
We need to assert that layer 4
actually gets stronger because
it includes different
ideologies.
That's right.
Its primary function is
constitutional deterrence, and
loyalty to that function has to
supersede any party creed.
The fact that new opposing
groups are joining validates the
core theory that the amendment
was never meant for just one
demographic.
That should be the triumphant
part of this section.
It should.
The architecture is so robust
that it works even when its
members despise each other's
political goals.
That's a great point.
I mean if the deterrent only
works when everyone agrees on
who the threat is, then it's
just a political tool.
But if it works when people
disagree on everything except
preventing a monopoly by layers
one and three, then it's truly
architectural.
Precisely.
The author can frame that
skepticism, the fear about how
they'll vote, as minor political
noise that proves the success of
the safeguard.
Layer 4 is designed to function
even when people disagree on
everything else.
The stability comes from
accepting that principle of non
monopoly even when it's
politically uncomfortable.
That clarifies the distinction
perfectly, the ephemeral
political squabbles versus the
enduring constitutional
structure.
It shows the architecture is
designed to withstand
disagreement, not eliminate it.
A much higher and more
persuasive bar to clear.
So these three changes,
deepening the cost analysis,
leveraging the personal journey,
and then solidifying the
argument for diversity, they all
focus on maximizing the impact
of the core ideas.
I agree the piece is already
conceptually brilliant.
These revisions just push it
beyond intellectual defense and
toward, well, toward becoming a
truly unassailable framework.
They ensure that when a reader
finishes, they understand the
Second Amendment isn't just a
right, it's a necessary and
costly design feature.
Excellent.
OK, so to quickly recap for our
listener, we have 3 actionable
suggestions.
First, you have to fully
integrate the intellectual cost,
the burned carbon, to strengthen
the sequestered carbon
deterrent.
Don't hide the societal cost.
Argue it's the necessary trade
off for constitutional
contingency. 2nd resequence that
opening.
Use the author's powerful
personal journey as a convert to
create a more compelling hook.
Start with that personal
realization before you dive into
the abstraction of the four
layers.
And finally, clarify and amplify
the message on diversification.
Show that the amendment strength
is proven by including different
ideologies rather than letting
political skepticism undercut
the core thesis of parity.
This essay really has the
potential to fundamentally shift
how people see the role of
private firearms in the US
system.
We strongly encourage you to
implement these changes.
It's already a very powerful
piece.
These revisions are just about
maximizing its intellectual
impact and ensuring its reach
extends far beyond those who
already agree with the premise.
We look forward to seeing the
revised version.
Please submit your improved work
back for today we.
Are taking on a subject that is
usually just dominated by these
huge cultural and political
arguments.
A huge understatement, right?
Right, but we're going to
approach it as a purely
architectural problem, The role
of firearms in American Civil
society.
Exactly.
We are stepping completely
outside the usual debates.
I mean, we're not talking policy
prescriptions, crime rates, or,
you know, historical context in
that way.
No, our mission today is to
analyze a single, and I think
very radical structural thesis
from an author.
And what is that thesis?
That the staggering volume of
legally owned, privately
maintained arms in the United
States creates this persistent,
unignited structural deterrent,
and that this fundamentally
alters how power works in the
American Republic.
And that thesis is packaged
under a phrase that really, I
mean, it just grabs your
attention.
Sequestered carbon, how half a
billion privately owned firearms
form a structural counterweight
in US civil society.
It frames this whole issue not
as a cultural thing, but as a
component of the nation's, I
guess, operating system, a deep
seated latent energy source.
It's a great metaphor.
The central argument is that the
United States has this unique
structural feature.
I mean unique compared to
virtually every other modern
developed nation.
And that feature is the number.
It's the sheer scale we are
talking about approximately half
a billion privately owned,
legally maintained firearms that
together function as a
counterweight inside the
established architecture of
power.
OK, so not an insurgency, not a
political lobby.
No, nothing like that.
It's a foundational structural
reality.
So we have to unpack that term
sequestered carbon, because
that's really the key to the
whole framework.
Here it is in science.
Sequestered carbon is dense
energy, right?
Stored potential that's just
held in reserve.
What does that mean when you
apply it to millions of rifles?
Well, it's a perfect metaphor
for I think 2 reasons.
First, it represents dense
kinetic potential energy, the
capacity for force.
But second, and this is the
crucial part, this potential
matters specifically because it
is not discharged.
Because it's not burned.
Exactly.
If that carbon is released, if
the force is actively used in,
say, chaos or violence, it stops
being a counterweight.
It just becomes a crime or an
emergency or rebellion.
And it would instantly trigger a
response from the other layers
of authority.
Instantly so.
The structural role of this
carbon comes entirely from its
state of dormancy.
So it's a massive potential
that's just held in reserve and
the very act of its maintenance,
its presence, constrains what
everyone else can do.
Absolutely.
The author even calculates the
cost of maintaining this
deterrence.
You know, the discipline
required, the legal liabilities,
the mental load of
responsibility.
That's the energy cost of
sequestration.
Right.
And that cost is far, far
preferable to the societal cost
of burning.
It should be a total
constitutional failure.
The state or any other authority
has to calculate the potential
cost of unsealing that carbon
before it tries to do something
that assumes its power is
totally unopposed.
That calculation, that
acknowledgement, that authority
is not unopposed, that brings us
to the mission of this deep
dive.
Our goal is to unpack this
argument that these arms are a
persistent 4th layer of power, a
layer that exists to prevent a
monopoly of force by any other
layer.
And its ultimate purpose,
according to this thesis, is to
make sure that the exercise of
power stays contingent on
consent and, critically, that
consent remains structurally
revocable.
Revocable if the whole
foundation of the Republic is
threatened.
Precisely.
And to really get how unique
this claim is, we have to
understand where the author is
coming from.
This isn't someone who grew up
in, you know, American gun
culture.
Not at all.
They approached this from the
outside, living in places where
the relationship between the
citizen and the state over arms
was completely the inverse of
the US model.
And that gives them a really
unique comparative perspective
it.
Really.
Does.
The author talks about living in
places like Hawaii where gun
ownership, while, you know,
technically legal, was
culturally peripheral?
It was discouraged through just
bureaucratic inertia and social
pressure.
Not seen as part of civic life.
No.
Then they moved to Washington,
DC in the late 80s, right after
the handgun ban.
Legal ownership there was almost
theoretical.
So the Second Amendment was just
an abstract legal idea and not a
tangible thing.
Right.
And then you contrast that with
their time abroad.
They lived in the UK where
access to firearms is
fundamentally a steep granted
exception.
You have to prove to the state
why you're worthy.
It's not a right, it's a
concession.
A concession based on risk
management or the Netherlands
we're getting permission depends
entirely on proving, you know,
strict discipline and a specific
need like competitive sports.
The default is restriction.
The burden of proof is on you.
Totally.
And in Germany, particularly
Berlin, the attitude is
extremely rigid.
It's just a regulated risk
management process run by the
government.
The idea that arms could be a
civil right, let alone an
architectural feature, is just
alien.
So it wasn't until the author
moves to Virginia in the 20
tens, after decades of seeing
all these other models, that
they actually got their first
firearm.
And that shift was profound.
The Second Amendment went from
being this historical artifact
debated by lawyers, a symbolic
right, to something concrete,
something architectural.
And that's the core inside of
the source material.
That's it.
In the US, the right isn't a
symbolic nod to history, it's a
literal piece of the
foundational structure designed
to distribute power.
The experience of just owning
the means of force, even if you
never use it, made that
guarantee tangible.
It forces the other layers of
power to constantly acknowledge
that limit.
Yes, that shift from symbolic to
architectural is crucial.
So we have to analyze this
structurally.
Let's define the architecture by
first looking at the system.
Most nations operate in the
three functional layers of
authority.
Right, we have to establish the
norm to understand the American
divergent.
In almost all political science,
authority is segmented into
these 3 broad categories that,
you know, interact, they
compete, and sometimes they even
merge.
And layer one is the one we all
see the visible civic surface.
Official local governance.
Right.
This is your City Council,
mayors, precincts, zoning
boards, the IRS, the legitimate
bureaucratic authority.
It operates within the law.
Manages traffic issues, permits,
collects taxes, the standard
visible stuff.
The standard accountable
authority structure.
But of course, the world is full
of places where layer one's
legitimacy or its ability to
enforce its will just isn't
enough.
And that vacuum creates layer 2.
Shadow Authority Layer 2 is
fascinating.
And you know, depending on where
you are, it's deeply
frightening.
These are the networks that pop
up outside the law globally.
You're talking about powerful
drug cartels, organized crime,
political gangs, patronage
networks.
They are, in effect, unofficial
governments.
Exactly.
They fill the void in many
communities around the world.
Layer 2 is the entity that
actually governs, feeds, employs
and protects people or terrifies
them.
If layer one can't guarantee a
contract, layer 2 might enforce
it with violence.
They create their own parallel
economy, their own justice
system.
And critically, layer 2 is
fundamentally anti
constitutional.
It operates completely outside
the rule of law.
It seeks power not through
consent, but through fear,
violence and money.
So it's a rival, an illegitimate
power center.
Often in direct competition with
lower one.
OK, so that brings us to the
third layer.
When local governance and these
internal shadow forces can't
maintain order, or when a state
actor wants to impose its will
on everyone, you get layer 3.
Federal or external intervention
Layer 3 embodies the
overwhelming capacity of
centralized force the national
government, its regulatory
agencies, federal task forces,
the military.
Or in failed states, could be
peacekeepers or occupation
forces.
Right.
The role of layer 3 is to impose
order by sheer force of
capacity.
They have the massive
centralized resources, air
power, cyber capabilities, mass
surveillance, and the authority
to suppress the other two
layers.
Or, in the worst case, to become
the dominant power themselves.
And essentially replace layer
one with a totalitarian
structure.
Now if you look globally, you
see how these three interact in
highly centralized nations.
Layer one suppresses layer 2 and
it all operates under the shadow
of layer 3.
Authority is top down,
unchallenged.
Right, but in other places, say
large corrupt nations, layer 2
can dominate cartels hold the
real power and layer one becomes
just a formality.
And layer 3 might be too corrupt
or just too inefficient to do
anything about.
It and then in totalitarian
regimes, layer 3 just imposes
order by absolute force, force
crushing the other two.
In all those cases, one layer
achieves a near total monopoly
on force.
And the American model,
according to this analysis,
diverges sharply from all those
scenarios.
Specifically because of the
persistent structural pressure
from this layer 4, this
counterweight is what makes the
system less prone to those
absolute monopolies you see
elsewhere.
So the architecture itself
includes this constant latent
challenge to the whole concept
of a monopoly on force.
Yes, the presence of layer 4
means that every action by layer
one or layer 3 has to implicitly
factor in the potential cost of
activating that massive
dispersed potential energy.
So let's drill down on that.
Let's get to the architecture of
this divergent the fourth layer,
privately owned, arms,
dispersed, unorganized,
uncentralized, but just there.
And it is a diffused phenomenon.
That's key.
It's half a billion arms,
legally owned, spread across the
entire country, every
demographic.
It's not a formal organization.
It has no headquarters, no
leader.
It's a state of dispersed
capacity.
That's a perfect way to put it.
And defining its core function
is so important here because
this is where we separate the
concept from all the cultural
arguments.
The purpose isn't sport or
recreation or even stopping a
burglar.
No, although those are, you
know, acknowledged by products.
They reinforce the cultural
legitimacy of it.
But the constitutional core is
parity.
That is the analytical
centerpiece of the source
material.
Parity meaning what exactly?
Meaning that Layer 4 exists to
ensure that the collective
diffused force available to the
populace is sufficient to deny
any other layer, a corrupt local
government, a rising cartel, and
overreaching federal government,
the fantasy of unopposed force.
So the goal is to maintain the
Republic's structural integrity
to make sure power remains
contingent on consent and that
consent remains revocable.
Exactly the moment Layer 3 The
federal government believes it
can just dictate terms without
calculating the cost of
widespread opposition.
The Republic shifts.
It goes from constitutional
negotiation to enforce
compliance.
And the author is very clear
about what layer 4 is not.
Very clear.
It is not insurgency.
It's not subjugation, militia,
rebellion, or paranoia.
It's a stable, dormant
component.
If it actively tried to govern
or overthrow, it would instantly
forfeit its architectural
function.
And that forfeiture is key.
It is.
If layer 4 acts outside the law,
it immediately draws the
overwhelming centralized force
of layer three against it.
Its value is in its potential,
not in its application.
And this function, this idea of
latent parity, this is
continuous from the founders
contacts.
Right, absolutely.
When they wrote the Second
Amendment, they were explicitly
concerned about standing armies,
about internal usurpations.
The need for a civilian
counterweight was paramount, and
it was rooted in their
historical experience with
tyranny.
But the author has to address
the critics who point to the
change in technology.
I mean we've gone from a 1791
muzzle loader to a modern semi
automatic rifle.
Of course, but the argument is
that while the category weapon
changed drastically the purpose,
the architectural requirement
for parity did not.
If the Second Amendment only
protected obsolete tools, the
parity would crumble.
And the amendment will become
purely symbolic.
The courts, in reaffirming that
it protects contemporary arms,
are essentially protecting
contemporary parity.
If the citizens means of
deterrence is hopelessly
outmatched, the structural check
fails.
OK, this brings us right to the
big challenge from critics, the
paradox of the unused deterrent.
We have 500 million arms, but we
don't see them producing daily
vigilantism or insurrection or
fighting cartels.
So if the deterrent value is
real, why isn't it used?
And this is where that
sequestered carbon analogy is so
important.
The counterpoint is critical.
The deterrence value is derived
purely from its non use.
Unused deterrent is the very
definition of deterrent success.
So if it were being used, the
system would already be in a
state of constitutional crisis
or civil war.
Signifying failure?
Yes, the author uses some great
analogies for this.
Like the nuclear one?
Right.
Nuclear arsenals don't fail
because cities remain unburned.
Their success is measured by the
stability they enforce the idea
of mutually assured destruction.
Or in this case, mutually
assured protracted conflict.
The deterrent works by taking
away the opponent's ability to
act without consequence.
It forces negotiation, debate
and the tedious legal process
rather than swift imposition by
layer 3.
And there was another one, the
fire extinguisher.
Yeah, fire extinguisher isn't
pointless just because your
kitchen is still standing.
Its value is entirely
anticipatory.
Its presence constrains your
behavior.
You're less likely to be
reckless with fire if you know
the means to stop a catastrophe
is right there.
So layer 4 is the structural
fire extinguisher built into the
Republic.
That's the idea.
Its function isn't measured in
conflicts one, but in conflicts
prevented and negotiations
forced.
OK, so that leads to a really
important qualifier, the self
policing mechanism.
If layer 4 is defined by its
restraint and allegiance to the
Constitution, what stops it from
just degrading into layer 2 into
another form of shadow
authority?
The restraint is mandatory.
The author is very clear that
the people who make up layer
four are defined less by the
equivalent they have and more by
the restraint they practice.
And the principles they uphold.
Yes.
If a person unseals the carbon
irresponsibly, if they brandish
a weapon, commit a felony,
threaten authority outside the
bounds of self-defense, they are
immediately expelled from layer
4.
And who does the expelling
layers 1 and 3?
Exactly.
The local police and the federal
authorities.
A felony conviction immediately
voids your participation.
You lose the right to own the
means of force.
So layer 4 is only
constitutional if it adheres
strictly to the law and the
principle of responsible
maintenance.
And that's the crucial barrier
that keeps it from merging with
layer 2.
It is.
Layer 2 is fundamentally anti
constitutional.
It uses force to subjugate.
Layer 4.
Center of loyalty is the
Constitution itself.
Regardless of which political
party is in charge of layer one
or three at the moment.
Precisely, Layer 2 is about
personal gain.
Criminal Enterprise Layer 4
exists dormant and bound by law
as a safeguard for the
constitutional architecture.
So if a cartel, which is layer
2, has enormous firepower,
they're outside the law and
layer 3 is actively hunting
them.
But if a constitutional citizen
layer 4 has similar firepower,
they're within the law, and
layer 3 is constrained by that
fact.
That is the profound difference.
It's not about the type of
weapon, it's about the rule of
law and the constitutional
principle of parity.
They sit adjacent in terms of
means, but philosophically and
legally they are worlds apart.
OK, that distinction really
explains the structural
stability argument.
So let's pivot to what's been
happening over the last couple
of decades, because the
interaction between politics,
the courts and culture has been
fascinating.
It's been a remarkable dynamic.
You have these political
movements framing firearms as an
exceptional danger, a crisis, an
epidemic, and at the exact same
time, the judiciary has been
doing the complete opposite.
Yes, as the political rhetoric
ratcheted up, seeking to
restrict Layer 4, the judiciary,
starting roughly around the
Heller decision, began this
concerted effort to return to
the amendments, you know, source
code.
Focusing on the architectural
function, not just historical
practice.
Right.
They reaffirm the parody
argument.
The core finding was that the
Second Amendment protects
contemporary arms.
Because if it didn't, the
constitutional check on
government power would just
become obsolete.
Which makes sense if the state
can deploy modern tools, but the
citizen is restricted to
muskets, the idea of parity is
meaningless.
It's a joke.
So the courts are reinforcing
the concept that the right to
self-defense, especially against
potential state overreach, has
to be technologically relevant
to the means of imposition.
And the source argues this legal
trend isn't just judicial
activism, it's reflecting A
deeper cultural recognition.
Yes, that the electorate,
independent of any lobbying, is
increasingly viewing the Second
Amendment as constitutional
architecture, not just a
recreational license or a rural
cultural thing.
And that underlying recognition
is driving the advocacy shift
we've seen.
It is.
For decades, the NRA was this
singular gravitational body,
centralized and focused.
But the grassroots demand for
constitutional parity was much
broader than one organization
could contain.
So we've seen this shift to
decentralized litigation, the
rise of groups like Gun Owners
of America, the Firearms Policy
Coalition.
What's the structural
significance of that?
It reinforces the author's point
that demand preceded advocacy.
The principle is so widespread
and deep seated that even if one
big lobby collapses, the
momentum continues, driven by
all these decentralized actors.
It proves the political
existence of layer 4 isn't
dependent on a single
organization.
Not at all.
But maybe the most dynamic, and
I think truly fascinating modern
development is what the author
calls the modern realignment.
The diversification, the.
Diversification of who
participates in layer 4.
It's a profound cultural shift.
You have common commentators
increasingly noting that groups
traditionally outside the legacy
gun culture are now arming
themselves.
You're talking about LGBTQ
activists, leftist organizers,
minority communities,
progressive coalitions.
All of them.
They're now participating in
Layer 4 maintenance.
They're seeking the structural
parity the amendment offers,
often driven by fears of Layer 2
threats, political violence,
hate groups, social upheaval.
And what's remarkable is the
reaction from the long standing
Second Amendment advocates, the
traditional participants.
Their response has generally
been 1 of sincere welcome.
And why is that welcome a
structural stabilizer?
Because the principle itself
gets stronger, the function of
the Second Amendment was never
meant to empower only one
demographic or political party.
If participation diversifies, it
makes it geometrically harder
for any political faction to
successfully frame the arms or
the principal as belonging to
just one ideology.
It stabilizes layer 4 by making
it truly nonpartisan and
function.
Even if the individual
participants still have their
political biases, the presence
of a much more diverse spectrum
of participants makes the
argument for parity
exponentially more robust.
The deterrent is stronger when
it reflects the entire society.
It becomes a truly national
constitutional reality, not just
a regional or cultural footnote.
Exactly.
But the source does note there
is some lingering skepticism
within that legacy community.
There is, and it's not grounded
in identity, but in continuity.
That's a critical attention
point.
It is.
The question being implicitly
asked by the long standing
participants is not should you
have one, it's will you later
vote to forbid mine.
The fear is that the new
participants are adopting the
practice of ownership for
immediate self-defense, but they
might ultimately abandoned the
principle of constitutional
parity for all citizens.
Right.
The concern isn't about the
physical arms they own, but
whether they share that
underlying philosophy of
constitutional distrust of
centralized power, the very
philosophy that requires Layer 4
to exist.
So if they see their own gun as
just a temporary solution to a
momentary problem and not as a
permanent architectural
safeguard.
Regard for everyone.
Then the structural
counterweight is just being
borrowed, not adopted.
If they eventually align with
political groups that want to
dismantle the principle for
others, they weaken the entire
structure.
So the ultimate fate of Layer 4
depends on whether this new wave
of participants embraces the
idea that the right is
architectural, protecting
everyone, even those they
disagree with, or if they see it
as just situational.
That's the question.
If the principle remains intact,
the layer 4 solidifies this
position as an indispensable
constitutional check.
The diversification strengthens
the Republic.
OK, so let's zoom out and pull
all this together.
What does the existence of Layer
4, the sequestered carbon,
actually mean for the structural
integrity of American
governance?
It connects right back to the
idea of the constitutional
operating system.
The US is designed as a
constitutional Republic, which
means it resists pure democratic
control.
It's voting plus veto majority
plus safeguard.
Representation plus limitation.
The whole system is built on an
inherent distrust of
consolidated power.
And later 4 acts as an implicit
structural veto on any attempt
to just wholesale replace that
architecture without consent.
It ensures that terms cannot be
dictated without negotiation
because the potential cost of
enforcement is just too high.
And this is that stability
paradox we talked about earlier.
It is the existence of half a
billion privately owned
functional firearms in a state
of dormancy without widespread
revolt or mass vigilantism that
doesn't signal failure.
It signals A profound and
successful form of stability.
The deterrence is working
precisely because layers one and
three, the local and federal
power structures, have
internalized the cost of
unsealing that carbon.
They continue to operate within
constitutional bounds, even when
they're frustrated because the
alternative is unacceptable.
If the deterrent was failing,
we'd see one of two things
pervasive organized violence or
total government overreach
leading to that conflict.
Exactly.
The fact that the massive
centralized military of Layer 3
operates under strict civilian
control and the rule of law
suggests the deterrence is
working as intended.
It eliminates the political
fantasy of total, unopposed
control.
It fundamentally reinforces the
American idea that authority is
always contingent, monopoly is
always provisional.
No single layer.
Not local government, not
organized crime, not the federal
military can claim complete
control because the baseline
level of latent force available
to the citizenry is too high and
too dispersed.
And the ultimate take away from
the author is that citizenship
in this context is performed not
just at the ballot box and in
rhetoric, but in the quiet,
responsible maintenance of
parity.
It is a persistent state of
constitutional preparedness that
forces political negotiation and
dialogue to remain the dominant
way we make change.
The structural impact of that is
just staggering.
The author posits that the very
freedom critics used to denounce
the existence of these arms is
paradoxically guaranteed by
their presence.
Stored potential enforces
peaceful process.
It's the sequestered carbon
maintained, not consumed.
It is not a sign of America
losing control.
According to this thesis, it is
the reason no single political
layer can seize total control.
The structure is just entirely
unique to the American
experiment.
It forces us to view the
presence of these arms not as a
social illness, but as a core
pillar of the constitutional
operating system.
Designed explicitly to prevent
the system from ever collapsing
into a three layer monopoly
which is so common everywhere
else in the world.
Absolutely.
The structural function of
restraint enforced by this
potential parity is what allows
everything to function.
It lets layer one govern without
fear of layer 3 tyranny, and it
constrains layer 2 criminal
syndicates by maintaining a
strong baseline of lawful
citizens.
So let's leave you with this as
a final, provocative thought to
Mull over.
The global perception of
American instability almost
always focuses entirely on the
political noise, the
polarization, and, you know, the
tools themselves.
But how might that global
perception shift if we were to
focus on this architectural
reality, the function of
restraint that's enforced by
this sheer mass of potential
force?
If the world understood that the
guns are structurally the reason
the state cannot operate with
unopposed dictatorial force,
what would that change about the
understanding of American
stability?
What if the highest level of
stability is achieved not by
disarming the populace, but by
ensuring that power remains
contingent on their consent?
And the United States is
operating on a constitutional
principle that almost the entire
rest of the world has abandoned,
A fascinating concept to hold on
to.
Indeed, something to explore
further on your own.
Thank you for joining us today.
We are diving into a very unique
and I would argue a structurally
crucial aspect of the US power
architecture, the vast dispersed
capacity of privately owned
firearms.
The source material frames this
with a really powerful metaphor,
calling it sequestered carbon.
It suggests that the the
dormancy of roughly half a
billion private arms constitutes
an active, structural 4th layer
of power within the system.
And that framing, I think takes
us directly to our central
question for today.
We have to ask whether the sheer
volume of latent capacity this
potential energy truly functions
as an independent ongoing layer
of political power.
I mean, does the non use of all
this firepower really amount to
a structural deterrent that
ensures government consent is
always contingent?
Or is its value primarily
conceptual, you know, reliant
entirely on the enforcement
mechanisms of the traditional
layers of authority, Layer one,
local governance and layer
three, federal intervention?
Well, my position is pretty
clear on this.
I hold that these arms form an
indispensable architectural
counterweight.
Their persistent, unorganized
existence fundamentally
eliminates the option of a
stable, unopposed monopoly of
force by any other layer.
It is a necessary background
condition, really, for
legitimate governance in the US,
signaling stability precisely
through its dormancy.
The sequestered carbon, that
potential energy, is the
provisional authority.
And I come at it from a slightly
different angle.
I'm going to question whether
this potential energy alone
constitutes A functional layer
of power, especially if that
energy is never politically
expressed outside of, say, the
judicial system.
I'll be arguing that the
stability you're observing is
actually better explained by the
enforcement mechanisms of layers
1 and 3, which actively ensure
layer 4 remains dormant and
constrained.
OK, so to articulate this fourth
layer concept, we first have to
recognize how it diverges from
standard national models.
Most nations, you know, they
operate within 3 layers.
Layer one is your local official
governance.
Layer 2 is the shadow authority,
cartels, gangs, organized crime.
And layer 3 is that centralized
federal or external
intervention. the US model is
unique because those half
billion privately owned arms,
dispersed, uncentralized and
persistent, they form layer 4.
It's situated beneath layer 3,
it's adjacent to layer 2, and it
runs parallel to layer one.
That structural map is helpful,
I'll give you that.
But what is its function beyond
merely existing as a a large
pile of potential energy?
It's constitutional core is
maintaining parity.
I mean, the founders designed
this system to prevent standing
armies from becoming the sole
source of force and to ensure
that internal usurpations remain
basically impossible without
incurring A catastrophic
national cost.
The purpose of this layer isn't
recreation, or even just
self-defense.
It is ensuring that power
remains contingent on consent.
The deterrent is defined by its
elemental nonuse, much like, you
know, the fire extinguisher
metaphor in the source material.
A fire extinguisher isn't
feeling because the kitchen
isn't on fire.
It's dormancy, signals stability
and a provisional monopoly of
force.
I see why you think that.
And that fire extinguisher
analogy is it's elegantly
constructed, I'll admit, but I
believe it grants too much
credit to latency, and it
ignores the active role of
existing governance in
maintaining that latency.
Let's go back to the source
materials critics for a second.
If 500 million arms have not
produced mass insurrection or
active anti cartel vigilance
actions you'd expect from a true
counterweight, then the argument
that the deterrent is real
becomes purely philosophical.
We have to ask, what is this
sequestered carbon do if it
never combusts or, you know,
even flares up?
What it does is make the
calculation of unopposed force
impossible.
It forces every single
interaction between the
government and the populace to
be managed through legal process
rather than raw coercion.
But this leads directly to the
core issue of constraint.
If layer 4 is truly independent
and operating parallel to layer
1 and beneath layer three, why
is it so rigorously dependent on
them for its own continued
existence?
The source material makes this
very clear.
The moment an individual unseals
the carbon, irresponsibly
commits a felony, threatens or
brandishes a weapon outside the
context of self-defense, they
are immediately neutralized and
expelled from layer 4 by the
enforcement mechanisms of layers
1 and 3.
Right, but that expulsion
confirms its boundary and its
internal loyalty to the
constitutional system.
It doesn't confirm a lack of
power.
If layer 4 didn't respect the
boundaries of layers one and
three, it would simply be layer
2.
Just unorganized crime or
insurgent activity?
But that means the celebrated
stability is derived from the
established authority enforcing
the rule of law, not from the
latent force of layer 4 itself.
I mean, the restraint practice
by gun owners is not some
spontaneous internal moral code
independent of the state.
It is externally enforced by the
police and the justice system.
The club is self policing only
and I'm quoting here by the fact
that police enforce the
consequences.
So layer 4 is conditioned and
restrained by the very layers it
is supposedly meant to condition
and restrain.
That relationship suggests
dependence, not independence.
That brings us directly to our
first big contention here.
The nature of this power is it
architectural versus enforcement
dependent.
I maintain the capacity as
architectural, a core structural
feature that shapes the very
possibilities of governance.
We've seen significant judicial
action over the last two
decades, rulings that expand
access and protect contemporary
arms far beyond traditional
conceptions.
Now, this isn't layer 3, the
courts merely protecting a
recreational right.
It's layer 3, confirming the
limits placed on layers one and
three by the existence of layer
4.
OK, but courts ruled on the
right to possess certain items.
How does the protection of a
right translate into a
functionally independent layer
of power that influences daily
political calculations?
When the state wants to regulate
firearms, they don't negotiate
terms with layer four.
They pass legislation and then
wait for Layer 4 to appeal to
Layer 3, the Supreme Court, for
protection.
But consider the political
calculation.
Imagine Congress attempts A
unilateral mass disarmament
campaign, something far beyond
current regulatory Tory debates.
The courts.
Layer three may eventually
strike it down shore.
But the reason Congress has to
fear the political cost, the
resistance, the constitutional
challenge, the fundamental
breakdown of consent.
That reason is layer 4.
The momentum is driven by
decentralized litigation and the
electorate's recognition that
the amendment protects
contemporary parity, meaning
arms capable of challenging
modern state force.
This shows a political will that
precedes and drives the advocacy
groups.
But that fear is predicated on
two things.
First, the courts layer 3
stepping in, which is a
structural dependence, and 2nd
the fears of chaos, not of
organized political action.
I'm sorry, but I just don't buy
that the architecture is
independent when its primary
condition, restraint and
dormancy, is enforced by the
police.
If that external enforcement
stopped, the result would be
civil collapse, which means
layer 4's power is just the
threat of collapse, which is
always inferior to the effective
power of a functional state.
The power of layer 4 isn't
measured by its capacity to
start a revolt, but by its
capacity to prevent layer one or
layer 3 from acting without
constitutional accountability.
This constraint has to be
managed by the system itself.
If the system tried to violently
suppress layer 4, the conflict
that would result would justify
the architecture in the 1st
place.
The circular logic you're
pointing to that stability
proves the deterrent, but the
deterrent is only allowed to
remain sequestered because of
enforced stability.
That's actually the definition
of successful deterrence.
We observe peace because the
cost of non peace is
catastrophically understood by
all three official layers.
But if that option to resist is
sanctioned as you're arguing,
why is the influence of layer 4
defined only by its non action?
If this Layer 4's loyalty is the
Constitution, then why isn't its
capacity activated or leveraged
to negotiate terms?
When constitutional challenges
or perceived overreach occur, we
see massive constitutional
disputes that don't mobilize
Layer 4 at all.
That suggests apathy or
satisfaction, or maybe just
political inertia rather than
some active deterrence enforcing
contingent consent.
If this sequestered carbon is
truly energy, why is it only
ever measured indirectly for
court filings?
Because the activation is
political and judicial, not
necessarily kinetic.
And that I think, brings us to
our second contention,
constitutional loyalty and
diversification.
This is where we see the
strengthening of the
architecture.
The source material highlights a
really critical modern
realignment.
I'm intrigued by this idea, I
admit, especially what it means
for the structure.
Well, when groups that were
historically excluded from
traditional gun culture, say
LGBTQ activists, leftist
organizers, or diverse urban
communities, when they begin
arming themselves, the reaction
from long standing Second
Amendment advocates is often
welcome, not hostile.
And this isn't just tolerance,
it's a recognition that
diversification strengthens the
core function of the amendment.
It proves the architecture was
written for the public, not for
a specific caste or political
faction.
That's an interesting point,
though I would frame it
differently.
While diversification might
demonstrate broader adoption of
firearm practice a functional
right, it doesn't necessarily
confirm a commitment to the
layer 4 principle of enforcing
constitutional consent against
government overreach.
If a leftist group arms itself
primarily to counter, say,
perceived fascist threats, or an
LGBTQ group arms itself for
self-defense against criminals,
layer 2 they are utilizing the
right, but they are not
necessarily adhering to the
architectural principle of
checking layer three federal.
Overreach, but by adopting the
practice, they adopt the
political calculus.
The center of loyalty for this
layer is the constitutional
architecture itself, not any
single party or administration.
The only lingering skepticism
among legacy gun owners,
according to the material, isn't
about the misuse of the tools by
new groups, but whether these
new participants will abandoned
the constitutional principle of
parity after they adopt the
practice, which would make Layer
4 politically fragile.
The diversification actually
makes the power structure more
resilient to political capture.
But how does that resilience
manifest practically against
layer 3?
If the armed population is
politically and ideologically
diverse, it actually makes the
possibility of coordinated
political action in defense of
layer 4 less likely, not more.
If the groups can't agree on
what constitutes overreach,
their potential kinetic power
just cancels out, which
reinforces the effect of
monopoly of layers 1 and 3.
Their mutual restraint is
enforced by their mutual
suspicion, which is a far cry
from a unifying commitment to a
structural deterrent.
No.
Their ideological diversity is
the mechanism that prevents a
single faction from dominating.
This decentralized ideological
commitment is its strength.
It makes any opposition to a
tyrannical move a hydra headed
problem, one that's impossible
to isolate or decapitate
politically.
And this fundamentally
complicates the political
calculus for any governing body,
federal or state, that's
considering restrictive
legislation or coercive
enforcement.
They face a decentralized
electorate, armed and
ideologically diverse, rather
than some centralized,
predictable opponent.
Look, if we accept that the
amendment exists to prevent
replacing the architecture
wholesale without constitutional
consent, then Layer 4's highest
expression should be a powerful
non judicial check, not just a
complicated political lobbying
map.
If Layer 4's loyalty is truly
the Constitution, why is its
influence defined only by its
nonaction and not by its
capacity to negotiate terms when
constitutional challenges arise?
The fact that it exists without
widespread her Volt or
confrontation suggests either
profound satisfaction with the
existing system, or that the
deterrent capacity is simply too
costly to ever deploy, rendering
it an unusable check.
The deterrent is used every
single time a piece of
legislation is drafted and then
discarded because its
enforcement would be
politically, socially and
physically impossible.
It is the background condition
that forces the state to use
judicial and political means
rather than military or coercive
ones.
The very knowledge that half a
billion arms are stored
eliminates the option of quick,
unopposed force.
That structural inhibition, that
sequestered carbon awaiting
activation, is the fourth layer.
It is the reason authority must
always be contingent.
And I still maintain that that
contingent nature is currently
enforced and maintained by the
very layers it is supposed to
inhibit.
The reliance on layers one and
three to maintain the required
restraint of layer 4 suggests a
hierarchy of dependence, not a
structural parity.
So for me, the existence of half
a billion privately owned
firearms in dormancy is not a
sign of failure, it is a sign of
profound stability.
This stored potential eliminates
the fantasy of unapposed force,
ensuring that authority is
always contingent and monopoly
is always provisional.
This structure forces peaceful
constitutional process because
the capacity for resistance is a
known constant in the
architectural equation.
And from my perspective, while
the physical capacity for
resistance is vast and certainly
unique to the US political
landscape, defining this
capacity as a functional,
independent fourth layer of
power relies too heavily on a
philosophical definition of
deterrence that emphasizes
potential energy over kinetic
control.
The actual operational
mechanisms maintaining stability
and requiring restraint rely
critically on the very layers of
authority, layers one and three
that layer 4 is supposedly
holding in check.
It remains A uniquely American
architecture defined by its
structural constraints.
And a profoundly complex 1 to
analyze, particularly when
political power dynamics suggest
that potential energy is claimed
to be a greater force than
kinetic action.
It certainly suggests there is
much more to explore and how
consent and limitation truly
operate in the American system.